[Música]
sou professor de matemática e acredito
que a educação seja um agente de
transformação e que possa que deve e que
vai é conseguir transformar a realização
de sonhos foi criado pela lei a tia que
fazia a faxina solteira ela criou a mim
os seus dois filhos com muita luta e
muita dedicação
[Música]
eu optei morar com a minha tia pois a
minha mãe trabalhava em uma loja de
departamentos e eu era muito apegado aos
meus primos
então eu hoje posso dizer que eu tenho
duas mães né
a infância das minhas mães foi uma
infância muito difícil porque elas foram
criadas numa estalagem no rio de janeiro
ela e quatro irmãos ficaram órfãs muito
cedo e romério que é irmão de seus pais
assumiu a tutela dos filhos para que
eles não fossem para um abrigo
minha tia foi uma criação que conseguiu
formar a mim professor meu primo que é
engenheiro e minha prima que é
assistente social na formação acadêmica
aos 3 por um período minha mãe passou
por momentos difíceis ela perdeu tudo
perder o emprego
ela perdeu a residência e no hotel
estava trabalhando naquele momento
resolvi alugar um imóvel onde eu fui
morar com ela para se restabelecer
três anos depois romério já aposentado
ele começa a desenvolver o mal de
alzheimer
como foi uma pessoa muito significativa
na minha vida já que ele assumiu como
pai quando minha mãe grávida ou eu fui
morar trouxe ele para morar comuns
foram dez anos cuidando do remédio 10
anos acordando à noite para trocar
fralda dez anos cuidando da sua higiene
tratando de suas cara mas dez anos não
de tristeza e de sofrimento dez anos de
aprendizagem momentos difíceis mais
momentos de aprendizagem fim
eu nunca cheguei à escola com as noites
mal dormidas é cansado tratando meu
aluno de forma arrogante ou grosseira
eu sempre continuei focando pelo bem das
crianças que estavam comigo é em 2014
com a morte do médio conseguiu ingressar
no mestrado no qual conclui em 2016
a escolha do magistério foi uma escolha
difícil pra mim eu tive preconceito até
da minha família porque quando eu optei
ser professor
eu ouvi na minha mãe assim graças a deus
o seu primo engenheiro então se algo lhe
faltava alguém para te amparar a isso é
muito difícil né você para uma profissão
que já têm dificuldades e você perceber
que o seu sonho já tem que ser
enfrentado dentro da sua casa
eu passei por uma universidade muito
distante
eram quatro horas para chegar da
faculdade até a universidade
eu pegava um ônibus e um trem e outro
ônibus
por muitas vezes o dinheiro contado né
dado pelo romédio pela minha mãe
eu dormia na condução pelo cansaço e
tinha que andar quilômetros a pé para
chegar à faculdade
uma coisa que me lembra muito que me
marcou muito foi quando é um trem em um
trem avaliou ficou preso entre uma
estação e outra e eu não consegui chegar
para a realização de uma prova
a começar com o professor
eu falei com ele
você pode me dar uma nova oportunidade
ele disse infelizmente não porque se
você fosse bom você passaria uma
universidade próxima à sua casa
a partir daquele dia nunca mais voltei
pra aquela faculdade mas eu não desisti
do meu sonho
ao chegar a casa eu conversei com a
minha tia perguntei você me dá uma nova
oportunidade para que eu termine um ano
estudando e eu possa ingressar em uma
universidade próxima à minha casa e ela
disse sim com certeza você vai conseguir
eu consegui eu consegui foram momentos
difíceis de estudo no momento em que
veio morar conosco o irmão da minha tia
portador dos vírus hiv
éramos quatro já morando num casebre e
nós nos dividimos para cuidar dele um
cadeirante então era todo um cuidado nem
cuidando de uma pessoa doente já em
estado com a doença em estado avançado
ele veio a falecer muito rapidamente e
uma coisa que eu comecei a falar sobre
sonhos cada um tem um sonho
alguns têm um sonho profissional tem um
sonho pessoal e um sonho pode ser de uma
dificuldade que você tenha o sonho do
meu tio era descoberta da cura da vacina
onde ele não conseguiu realizar
vocês já pensaram pra ele pra pensar
pararam pra pensar por exemplo hoje é o
maior sonho que vocês têm
eu sou professor há 23 anos quando a
gente trabalha no magistério a gente
lidar com vidas cada vida é uma história
cada história faz parte da gente
muitas me significa marcaram alguns
sonhos eu conseguir auxiliar ajudar
alguns ressignifica talvez alguns eu
tento foi o estado não sei
mas eu tenho certeza que alguns deles me
marcaram muito e eu vou contar alguns
primeiro eu vou contar a história de
valdecir
ao descer um aluno do ensino supletivo
noturno
logo no início da minha carreira
valdecir veio do interior do nordeste
com 25 reais no bolso e um sonho ser
ator
um caminhão de milan trocou seu serviço
de faxina por moradia alimentação e até
a mensalidade da escola que é uma escola
para pagar uma escola particular
valdecir hoje é um grande ator mas ele
possui um projeto em uma comunidade do
rio
deflagrada pelo tráfico onde ele
oportuniza através de oficina de teatros
a realização dos sonhos de crianças que
foram esquecidas
ele da oficina adultos para crianças
especiais para todos que estão inseridos
ali então pode-se dizer que valdecir
hoje ele é um oportuniza dor de sonhos
uma outra história que me marca muito é
marrom mas não foi meu aluno do 6º ao 9º
ano
ele também era de uma comunidade
deflagrada e um menino muito inteligente
ganhadores de olimpíadas de matemática
superpremiado um super vencedor em
várias medalhas
eu sempre dizia para o marrom conquiste
mas conquiste com humildade o segredo de
um vencedor é ser humilde mas não tinha
um sonho de ingressar no instituto de
engenharia militar
ele conseguiu conseguiu e não gostou
hoje ele cursa matemática aplicada numa
universidade particular do rio de
janeiro onde ele tem bolsa e recebem uma
ajuda de custo para se manter
ano passado a encontrar o marrom
eu perguntei a ele a matemática teve
grande significado na sua vida
as olimpíadas de matemática
foram tão marcante pra você e ele me
disse o seguinte o professor a olimpíada
de matemática foi um pretexto que o seu
utilizou para que nós nós percebêssemos
vencedores
ele entendeu tudo eu não quero formar
engenheiros
eu não quero formar matemáticos eu quero
aqui dentro na minha escola com crianças
de classe menos favorecida
cada um se descubra um vencedor escolher
aquilo que ele queira uma outra história
foi ana júlia ana júlia foi minha aluna
chegou ao sétimo ano reprovado em
matemática
ela vinha apenas em matemática um
shopping a reprovação em soco no
estômago
a estima lá em baixo uma menina que
vivia triste mas eu percebi que ela
amava resolver problemas de matemática
adorava desafios à folha na zona vão
participar de uma olimpíada
[Música]
ela falou é de marcar x múltipla escolha
falei não é discursiva
ela não só participou como ela venceu
ela foi medalha de prata e na ocasião na
premiação falei com a amazônia na júlia
nunca permiti permita que pessoas em
possibilitem a realização dos seus
sonhos cada obstáculo que você encontrar
cada dificuldades que você tiver tome
com um crescimento algo que vai fazer
com que você se torne melhor muda sua
vida muda seu destino
você é capaz de se aquilo que você
queira e ninguém vai dizer ao contrário
também da mesma legenda na zona recebeu
luiz augusto um aluno com déficit
cognitivo
quer dizer um menino que tinha muitas
dificuldades mas adorava resolver
problemas
ele também foi vencedor de uma olimpíada
de matemática hoje ele cursa o ensino
médio em uma instituição privada com
bolsa e está trilhando seu caminho
com certeza um caminho de sucesso de
superação
eu ainda tenho muita coisa realizar hoje
eu tenho muitos alunos um grau de
autismo diferentes da minha sala e eu
fico pensando que matemática eu preciso
construir para esse mundo é uma educação
pela matemática na educação para
matemática
eu quero construir a matemática que vai
fazer sentido na vida daquela criança
então é essa matemática que eu acredito
é essa é a matemática que eu quero
construir aqui eu venho conseguindo
então eu tenho muitos desafios nesse
processo eu percebi que cada um tem seus
limites suas limitações
cada um tem seu tempo cada um tem suas
angústias
cada um tem suas tristezas
cada um tem suas referências cada um tem
seus sonhos e fechando essa reflexão que
me começou com uma história que eu me
considero uma história de resiliência já
que foi alguma criança que veio de uma
classe menos favorecida que a escola ea
educação mim oportunizou e oportunizou a
realizar meus sonhos eu pergunto a vocês
que estão aqui hoje vocês oportunizam a
realização de sonhos das pessoas que ama
das pessoas que estão à sua volta
no seu convívio e os seus sonhos você
possibilita você cria situações para que
eles sejam realizados
nós vivemos tempos de ansiedade
depressão e doenças da alma
a escola não pode ser um lugar onde seu
primo
a matemática não pode ser uma matéria
que é grande a gente tem que construir
uma escola que oportunize uma escola que
valorize uma escola que respeite as
diferenças uma escola que inclua
então ao sair daqui hoje eu gostaria que
cada um fizesse uma reflexão
será que oportunizar a realização de
sonhos de pessoas
não é um crescimento pessoal para cada
um de vocês e não é um alimento para a
alma
[Música]
muito obrigado pelo
[Aplausos]